[Music]
all right
what's up guys mkbhd here and today we
of course had apple's expected
anticipated september 2021 event this is
where they announced the new iphone
lineup the new iphone 13s and a couple
other small things as well
here's the thing
this is a pretty small update overall
but you know apple's events are always
these huge grandiose things they had
tons of drone shots this year and of
course these amazing transitions
cinematography and lighting all through
the roof it looked incredible but then
it's all to announce like a couple small
updates to a few things so
felt like it didn't quite match but i
still have a bunch of thoughts on a lot
of the things they actually did talk
about plus some stuff you might not have
caught from inside the keynote so this
is all of that in one place so they
actually started with the ipads so we
got a new refresh baseline ipad honestly
it's still the best deal in the entire
tablet world in my opinion it is
basically the same on the outside it's
the same 10.2 inch size the same design
and that famous 329 dollar price but
with refreshed insides you got a new a13
bionic chip inside and there's also a
new 12 megapixel ultra wide selfie with
center stage just like the ipad pro so
even more than the ipad mini this is the
number one entry point for most people
getting their first ipad it's still the
most popular ipad
and
yeah pretty minor updates small stuff
but again to get ipad os 15
64 gigs of base storage
and like a pretty tried and true design
it's fine it won't make a lot of
headlines but
that's the easiest tablet to recommend
but then we also did get a new ipad mini
as well it's been a while since they
refreshed this but this would be the
biggest redesign or the biggest refresh
of the day just because this was the
redesign outside and inside
it's basically now
a tiny ipad air so full metal jacket in
four new colors and some nice curves at
the corners as you'd expect still a
single camera at the back now but with a
camera bump this time the last ipad mini
did not have a camera bump and that's a
new 12 megapixel camera along with a new
ultra wide at the front with center
stage as well it's got an a15 bionic
inside even though they didn't say it on
stage and also new 5g support in the
mini the star of the show though is
definitely the new 8.3 inch display with
thin bezels that fits in the palm of
your hand and also usb c in this one as
well so that means now
all of apple's ipads have
different chips
and they all now have usbc except for
the baseline ipad which still has
lightning and it's kind of interesting
now if you look at the lineup it's clear
that the ipad air needs another update
because now the ipad mini officially has
a better newer chip and better insides
than that ipad air but generally i'm
like a little bit torn on if i actually
want this mini or not i really like the
small form factor i've liked it for a
long time
but uh i'm going to miss 120 hertz not
being there this is a 60 hertz ipad and
i love the 120 hertz on the ipad pro and
i think that's going to be the reason i
stick with it but other than that the
mini is looking really good and we'll
talk more about 120 hertz in a second
don't worry but then we got onto
the apple watch we got apple watch
series 7.
now we might have seen some of those
rumors floating around about maybe a
square design
that
was just not happening it's not true so
we have another apple watch in the same
shape as before but this is mostly just
a bigger screen update happening here so
the bezels all the way around are 40
thinner than the series 6 and the screen
now does curve and sort of flow over the
edges a little bit right up to the metal
body and they really highlighted this
they made a big deal about it and
there's lots of other stuff about the
watch that's either the same or wasn't
talked about as much looks like the same
sensors maybe the same chip as far as i
can tell same buttons and the same
digital crown i i like the way the
bigger screen looks but i want to see it
in person i'm not sure how to feel about
it yet and it's not even a durability
thing like i i beat up the apple watch
all the time it's never
cracked never broken never even really
scratched that much i play ultimate in
it i land on it it's in the dirt and
turf all the time it's fine and the new
one actually has harder ceramic and
harder glass on the outside
but it's more of how it'll look and
we've seen this shape for a while with
the reflections all the way around the
sort of curved outsides of the apple
watch i feel like curving the display
all the way to the very very outside
like this and bringing text and things
like that all the way to the outside
while you can fit more on the screen
might reflect even more and make some of
that stuff harder to read we'll see
though i mean i'm planning on getting my
hands on everything i talk about in this
video so if you want to see the review
of the apple watch when it comes out
it'll be here pretty soon definitely get
subscribed but yeah apple watch pretty
minor update same shape just slightly
bumped on that screen it also charges 33
faster with an included usb c charger
and the larger display is also a bit
brighter so it should be more visible
more often oh they also added shared
workouts in
fitness plus so basically if you're on
facetime and you have share play they
added fitness plus workouts to shareplay
so you can work out with someone across
the country
with an apple fitness plus workout but
what i really wanted them to add is
group competitions you know the
competitions where you close your ring
apple the one thing i want from a new
apple watch update
is just to have group fitness
competitions
that's all i ask but then okay we
finally get to the phones the real
update a lot of you were here for which
is the lineup of iphone 13 iphone 13
mini iphone 13 pro and iphone 13 pro max
so most of what we've been seeing
develop turns out to be correct which is
that the iphone 13 series looks a lot
like the iphone 12 series but with two
main updates worth talking about the
display
and the cameras
so with the display all the new iphones
have brighter screens for visibility and
hdr a thousand nits on the iphone 13 and
1200 nits peak on the 13 pros and they
all have a 20
smaller notch so all the same face id
hardware is up there same selfie camera
and all that they've just finally
compressed it a bit to make the notch a
bit smaller give you some of that screen
real estate back and then the 13 pro and
13 pro max have finally done it they
finally added 120 hertz display to these
pro phones and i kind of suspected they
would do this but they've done it it's a
pro motion display and it's actually a
variable refresh rate from 10 hertz all
the way up to 120 hertz
and this is interesting because this is
now a real differentiator between the 13
and the 13 pro
and we'll see if regular people
like actually notice the difference and
really want to upgrade for the 120 hertz
i think a lot of people will notice but
this will be the real test and then also
you might be thinking oh okay how's the
battery life going to be now that we're
expecting a brighter 120hz display on
the pro phones but it's good to know
that apple's actually expecting a
slightly better battery life from one
and a half to two and a half hours of
use
better depending on which phone you get
um
which is good i mean i'm gonna have to
put these phones through their paces and
see what that actually turns into with
my real world use but it's good to see
that they don't expect the battery life
to go down so that's the display then
there are the cameras so lots of stuff
here per usual obviously you can see
there's a slightly new layout with those
dual cameras diagonal from each other
this time and the camera bumps are
definitely a bit larger especially with
those pro phones look at the cameras
they're getting pretty thick now not
gonna lie but the 13 and 13 mini have
new dual cameras both still 12
megapixels both with larger sensors and
larger apertures all around and sensor
shift optical image stabilization on the
main sensor
in theory this is great there should be
a bigger sensor plus better
stabilization to give you much better
low light and should catch up to the
competition but we shall see but then
the 13 pro and 13 pro max appear to have
matching cameras this year and they are
all better than the regular 13. so it's
triple cameras again they're all 12
megapixels again and they're all with
wider apertures than every camera on the
13 for even shallower natural depth of
field and even better light gathering so
also the telephoto lens is 3x this year
up from 2.5 x and all the cameras have
night mode now so i'm pumped to test
these new cameras
obviously with new hardware and a new
generation image signal processor it
should be both better photos and videos
also the new ultra wide can shoot macro
photos now
but what i'm really most excited about
is actually some of the features they
announced in video mode
so video on the iphone i've already said
is i think still the best in any phone
but two of the new features they've
added are two new video features and
those are
cinematic mode
and prores video so the cinematic mode
has a bunch of focus tricks and tools to
help video shooters better control focus
this is something a lot of people play
with on the iphone camera all the time
there's a smooth focus racking and an ai
based depth detection that lets you
adjust the level of fake blur and focus
rack between subjects in a way that
smoothly moves that blur it sounds
really cool in theory
but basically i'm watching apple's demos
and i've watched them back now a bunch
of times
and apple's demos are typically the
absolute best case scenario of what you
can expect the phone's cameras to be
capable of
but these to me didn't look that good
now maybe i'm pixel peeping maybe i'm
expecting a little too much out of a
tiny smartphone sensor and lenses but
the focus racks still hunted a little
bit sometimes like any other normal
smartphone tap to focus and of course
when you go from a really close up shot
to a really far one focus racking you
can see the edge of the frame move
because the iphone's lenses are not
parfocal but i'm definitely nitpicking
here this is you know apple claiming a
better focus control system with the
iphone camera
i gotta try it and i'll definitely
report back but that's something i'll be
diving into then the other thing i
mentioned was prores so you can now
shoot with the pros 4k 30fps prores
video on the iphone
unless you get the 128 gig baseline pro
iphone in which case
only 1080. so instead of moving the
baseline storage up to 256
they just literally disable this one
feature and it's like it's kind of
brutal i guess there could be a really
good technical reason for it maybe the
128 gig chips aren't reading or writing
fast enough to shoot 4k 30 prores
maybe they're just like scared you'll
fill up your storage too fast on 128
gigs and they just want to disable the
feature
either way
seems like they should explain but
that's really the major iphone updates
with the screen and the cameras this
year aside from that you do have new
specs the new a15 bionic chip is in all
these phones with a five core gpu and
the pro phone and a four core in the
regular there is also a slight battery
bump like i mentioned it's physically
bigger batteries and the new iphones are
actually a tiny bit thicker and a little
heavier than last year to accommodate
that same ceramic shield same ip68 same
flat side materials as last year so
you're looking at 699 for the iphone 13
mini 799 for the iphone 13
9.99 for the 13 pro and 10.99 for the 13
pro max
and since i know you were wondering
just so you know it's 15.99 for the
fully maxed out one terabyte iphone 13
pro max you're welcome so yeah a bunch
of a bunch of small upgrades overall i i
think the ipad mini might be the biggest
upgrade but on the phones
you know i'm pretty confident without
even handling the phones yet that you
probably don't need to run out and get
an iphone 13 if you already have an
iphone 12
but that 120 hertz on the pro phones
i'm into it obviously and i really like
a good 120 hertz screen but we'll have
to see that might be a good reason for
people with older iphones and maybe even
up to an 11 or 12 to think about the pro
phone we'll see all this stuff pretty
soon let me know what you want to see in
the reviews in the comment section below
there's a lot of stuff that i haven't
mentioned that's just even little tiny
stuff that'll be on the spec sheet let
me know what you want to see in those
videos but either way subscribe to see
those when they come out and that's been
it thanks for watching
catch the next one
peace